denis mukwege gay is the winner of the
2014 sakharov prize for freedom of thought
this gynecologist was rewarded by the
european parliament for his fight
for women victims of
sexual violence in the democratic republic of the
congo
or on parle tv went to
the  hospital that dr mukwege has created a
damning testimony on the abuses
committed in this region of africa
he is nicknamed the man who repairs
fans denis mukwege and gynecologists
for 14 years tirelessly he
treats victims of sexual violence or
south kivu in the republic  Democratic Republic of the
Congo a region devastated by wars
since the 1990s today
still armed groups
sow terror in the populations
their main target the fans and
through it all the Congolese society
the women who we treat here are
victims of  sexual assaults including
little sexual violence with really
extreme brutality good moment
ah well it's violent c  it is like is
with extreme violence by the introduction
of foreign objects at the level of
the genital apparatus whether it is the fire of the
plastic to heat or of bayonet with the
shooting etc
it is violent no nothing of sexual it should
not be confused with with  sexuality
is a way of torturing and torturing
someone at the level of their intimacy therefore
touching the deepest of in fact
their dignity
it is in the city of bukavu that
doctor mukwege and built the
panzi hospital  to help victims
of rape one of the pavilions of
the establishment is reserved for them the
patients who live there suffer from serious
after-effects
they are taken care of by
psychologists and social workers this
was the case of justin she was
savagely attacked  when she was
eight months pregnant she underwent this
surgery before she
recovered
we were in the fields working entrance
cultivating
now we had seen soldiers
who was running behind us is a
number of eight
yes soldiers and all his name raped
when when a woman was raped
they pass many were days and
so is not for me too I was sleeping
I was not sleeping but at  because of
the thick column and our
social assistance who assist us and give us a
lot of information a lot of
morals and the doctors also yes the
days that I arrived if she had told me
justine you will heal
in this region of the  world rape is
a weapon of war intended to terrorize
the populations and to force them to
abandon their lands
the basement of this part of the
democratic republic of the congo is
indeed full of precious minerals
whose exploitation arouses the greed of
armed groups c  it is an effective weapon
since sénart but which leads to
massive displacements and of the population
it is an army which terrorizes so on
the plan has traumatized people are
terrorized they are traumatized and therefore
those who agree to stay
he agrees to stay as slaves
since they are so afraid to
equip themselves as soon as they arrive that they
agree to submit and 1c
submitting in fact they work for
the bulk more than 40 thousand women victims
of sexual violence  have been
cared for by panzi hospital since its
inception in 1999
over the past six months more
than 30 operations have involved
children under the age of five the
youngest of the victims had barely six
months left today  i'm back
wanted to start we have more than ten
interventions you tell mrs camiré to
prepare the lady there that i'm going
if we're going to do about six
interventions and 20 we'll have as many
so we have more than twelve interventions
today this  are
very heavy interventions so we try to go a
little faster to put all the teams
on alert
the care of rape victims
often requires
corrective surgery
the sea is original others there are some who
are of traumatic origin by
the introduction of objects at the level of the
vagina and his performance a
controversial doctor links with the rectors
but also his touching
dystocia here the track he is very very
hot and for a style challenge other like the
one we have that we will often deal with
it is the introduction
of objects at the bottom of the ice bag
the patient's operation will last more
than six hours and will require
surgical techniques  at the cutting edge,
several surgeons will be at work,
including doctor guy bernard cadière, a
belgian doctor who has come to lend a hand,
unfortunately here we are dealing with the
consequences, we would have
liked others to be new, we could do a lot
more work on prevention
and this prevention  goes through the fight
against impunity because I believe that
if people who commit such acts
he knew were aware that doing an
act like that for real  brought me back
to answer for their actions before the
courts and tribunals
maybe that would change
something today this is not the
case doctor mukwege and has been
rewarded several times for his work
with women victims of rape and  of
sexual violence during
armed conflicts on October 21, 2014 the
european parliament awarded him the sakharov prize
for freedom of thought
a prize awarded to exceptional personalities
who fight
against intolerance fanaticism
and oppression for me i believe that  in
fact this message simply translates
the fact that the world is
interested in what is happening in the
congo it's been 15 years all the same who is the
congolese population going through
an indescribable situation
what if there are  spotlights that are
fixed on the that the
results should still be a
lasting peace process and that is the
solutions that we do not continue to
deal with the consequences but more  early to
deal with the real causes of this
crisis
the positions of doctor
mukwege and disturbs he
narrowly escaped an assassination attempt
since then he lives with his family
in the hospital grounds
a place he  practically never leaves
until the real engine
is these women I believe that these women
are courageous and I always ask myself
questions as she manages
to get out of it after so much suffering
in 10 million dehumanization  and that
she continues to hold on not only to
live but also to try to build
the family and the society I believe that
I have a lot of respect for these women
I feel very very
I feel small